Let's go to the news conference
>> You see several subject matter experts
from the unified command who introduced themselves
momentarily.
These individuals represent only a small fraction
of the many dedicated professionals working
around the clock on this complex response
effort.
We understand this is an extremely difficult
time for the families of the missing crew
members aboard the titan and our thoughts
go out to them and the crew.
The unified command team is working tirelessly
to bring all available assets and expertise
to bear as quickly as possible in response
to this complex operation.
We remain in close contact go with the family
members and the crew to ensure they're fully
aware of our current and future search efforts.
Additionally, we've made close contact with
the British and
[1:02:14 PM]
contact with the British and French consulates
general to make sure they're fully apriced
of our efforts.
We're incredibly grateful for the full spectrum
of international assistance that has been
provided including an expert sub mariner from
the royal Navy who is here with us serving
aboard as a critical member of our team.
Additionally, a team of highly fif teams are
en route to aid in the search more over, our
Canadian partners have been providing critical
leadership and significant response capabilities
since the beginning of our efforts.
Again, this is an incredibly complex search
operation requiring surface and subsurface
elements.
And our unified approach is critical.
The location of the search, 900 miles east
of cape cod and 400 miles southeast of St.
John's makes very difficult to mobilize large
amounts of equipment
[1:03:16 PM]
large amounts of equipment quickly.
We've been able to provide air and surface
search assets to search below the surface.
We currently have five service assets searching
for the "Titan" and we expect ten to surface
in the next few hours.
There are two rovs actively sxeching two more
are en route.
We've received incredible support with aviation
assets from our coast guard air station in
Elizabeth city, the air National Guard and
Canadian armed forces.
Today there are two back to back p-3 flights.
One is ongoing now totaling 14 hours of continuous
onscene coverage and two c-130 coverage all
throughout the day and into the evening.
Yesterday the Canadian p-3 detected underwater
noises in the search area.
As a result, rov operations were relocated
in an attempt to explore the origin of the
noises.
[1:04:16 PM]
Although the rov has not gotten results, they
continue.
Additionally it has been shared with our U.S.
Navy experts for further analysis which will
be considered in future search plans.
The surface search is now approximately two
times the size of Connecticut and it is up
to two and a half miles deep.
Exponentially expanding the size of the search
area.
We have to factor in ever changing weather
conditions, currents and sea states that expand
the the search area every hour.
There is an enormous complexity with this
case due to it being so far offshore and the
coordination between multiple agencies and
nations.
We greatly appreciate the outpouring of support
and offers to provide additional equipment.
The unified command continues to prioritize
assets and resources in order to provide the
best capability in the most timely manner.
This includes weighing multiple factors to
identify the most effective resources available
to the response operation.
[1:05:18 PM]
the response operation.
With careful consideration to timeliness of
equipment arriving on scene, usefulness and
ability to deliver assets to the search area.
Over the past 48 hours, we have through incredible
unit of effort mobilized and implemented a
tremendous amount of expertise.
In addition to the ships and aircraft previously
mentioned we've dispatched two subject matter
experts.
They will serve as search coordinators on
scene for underwater operations.
So I've been stressing unity of effort a lot
in this statement and that's because it is
absolutely critical to this complex operation.
Again, our thoughts and prayer are with the
crew of the "Titan" and their loved ones.
We will work as hard and quickly as possible
in an effort to locate them.
I will take a few questions.
Before I do that, I'm going to have each of
the members, the team, introduce themselves
and I'll take some questions.
>> Good afternoon.
[1:06:19 PM]
I'm Paul Hankins.
I'm the director for salvage operations with
the U.S. Navy's supervisor of salvage.
>> Hello, I'm Carl from the oceanographic
institute.
>> I'm an exchange officer currently serving
on the staff at Norfolk, Virginia.
>> Good afternoon.
Lieutenant commander Christie butler working
closely with Frederick.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> So a couple thing.
When you're in the middle of a search and
rescue, you always have hope.
That's why we do what we do.
With respect to the noises, we don't know
what they are to be
[1:07:20 PM]
don't know what they are to be frank with
you.
The p-3 detected noises.
That's why they're doing what they're doing.
That's why they put sonar in the water.
What I can tell you is we're searching in
the area where the noises were detected and
we'll continue to do so.
And we hope that when we're able to get additional
rovs which will get there in the morning,
the intent will be to search in those areas
where the noises were detected.
If they continue to be detected, and then
put additional rovs where the search was originally
taking place.
I hadn't heard 30-minute intervals.
Here's what I can tell you.
So I am not a trained ear for underwater aquatics.
That's why we have a team of experts analyzing
that data.
It was sent immediately to the Navy last night
and it was analyzed overnight.
They're still looking at it.
Inconclusive.
I think the important pieces.
We're searching in the area
[1:08:20 PM]
We're searching in the area where the noises
were detected.
>> Can you talk about the time line?
>> A time line in what respect?
Oh, okay.
So in terms of, we talked about the action
number.
I think there's an important point.
The oxygen, that's just one piece of data.
Right?
There are a lot of pieces of data that we
need to consider.
And we're continuously looking at that and
we're continuously doing that throughout the
search.
But that's not the only thing that is important.
Right now our efforts are solely focused on
the search.
That is certainly a dialogue happening.
But we're focused on searching at this point.
>> Is this a recovery or a rescue?
>> A search and rescue 100%.
We're smack dab in the middle of a search
and rescue and we'll continue to put every
asset we have to find the "Titan" and the
crew members.
[1:09:21 PM]
>> Can you confirm some sort of rectangular
object has been spotted?
There was some sort of report about that.
>> So a couple things.
The rovs, each one brings different capability.
The rovs diving today, what is the depth?
Yep, 4,000 meters.
And additional rovs arriving tomorrow have
additional depth capability.
With respect to an object, so yesterday, one
of the aircraft did see an object.
I will tell you this.
In search and rescue missions when aircraft
are flying continuously, there is stuff out
in the ocean that is floating.
We went back and looked at it.
We didn't determine it to be debris.
We don't think it correlates with the case
and it is not uncommon at all during an active
search.
You see things and then you go look at them.
>> When were these noises first heard?
Do you have any information in terms of food
and water that the
[1:10:21 PM]
terms of food and water that the men might
have on board?
>> So several p-3 flights have heard the noises
yesterday and we put assets there.
We relocated assets immediately.
With respect to food and water, it is my understanding
there are limited rations.
I can't tell you exactly how much they have
aboard but they do have some limited rations
aboard.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> I think you need to be careful.
We need to have hope, right?
But I can't tell you what the noises are.
What I can tell you, and I think this is the
most important point.
We're searching where the noises are and that's
all we can do at this point.
>> -- Right now about the status?
Are the noises continuing now?
>> So I just, it is my understanding the p-3
heard noises today as well.
I want to take an opportunity to invite Carl
to the podium to
[1:11:23 PM]
invite Carl to the podium to talk a little
bit about, he has more expertise in underwater
acoustics and complain to speak to that in
general.
There are noises below the surface of the
ocean.
>> Again, from the oceanographic institution.
The association a very complex place.
Obviously human sounds, nature sounds, and
it is very difficult to discern what the source
of the noises are at times.
I can tell that you this team has multiple
sensors.
They're in the area.
They're sending data back expeditiously to
the best in the world people to analyze that
data and then they're feeding the results
bag to the unified team and they're making
decisions.
So we're here in an advisory